okay Lindsay Lindsay where have you been
I've been looking for you for like
almost three weeks now since we last
spoke and you disappeared from Hollywood
yeah I went to jail you're in jail yeah
I am can you just be really brief about
what what for I don't need all the
details
yeah assault with a deadly weapon
assault with a deadly weapon yes I mean
I went into popeye's and put a knife to
somebody's throat why did you do this um
I was honestly coming off of drugs and I
drank a little bit of alcohol then I got
angry because uh nobody loves me I
thought that nobody loved me but Ben
does this is a daughter nice and about
three hundred thousand of my viewers
yeah yeah um thank you guys for all the
comments anyways yeah she just she just
got out of jail yeah I haven't been able
to read them you just go to jail just
that minutes ago right oh yeah
then I helps Ben is an old friend of
yours yeah though I've never met but
yeah he called me out of the blue and
said yeah if you saw the video and said
and then I've also been speaking with
your mom over the last couple weeks
how'd that go very well I mean very nice
I mean she we're all kind of violence
that was similar page that you know it
seems to me like your medication is a
big part of some of your problems yes
if you don't take them things go haywire
yeah it sounds like um yeah pretty much
I mean you didn't you'd agree with that
yeah it's a common story you don't Alan
because a lot of the people I'm talking
to we want to blame the drugs but
honestly the problem
more of a mental problem they're not
taking their medications so they end up
taking then they take drugs and then if
it looks like a drug problem but it's
honestly a mental issue yeah yeah so
you've been in jail for almost three
weeks two and a half weeks and how was
that uh jail sucks it's very cold in the
suicide dorm um they ignore you well
they ignored me they wouldn't give me a
grievance or a medical paper to speak to
the doctors they make it very cold in
the room when they whenever I told him I
was anemic they mistreat you very bad in
the dorm 1202 twelve Oh once not so bad
but 1403 is the mental place I was
supposed to get my clothes back but they
never gave them back to me don't know
why but whatever
I mean a lot of stuff escalated towards
me going to jail like almost being raped
I kind of almost did get raped actually
if I wouldn't put my knee up against his
chest and pushed him off and then just
like locked him in the head he wouldn't
and then screamed he wouldn't have left
me alone
I stayed in a tent with a guy that was
going to hurt me because he had a knife
and I said hey can I um can I hold your
knife because something don't feel right
so he gave me his knife that night he
went to sleep and I stayed up all night
if I hadn't have had that knife this guy
would it came in and hurt us because
this guy that I didn't know poked his
head in the tent and I swore I switched
off the switchblade and I said get the
[ __ ] out and he got pissed off so he
took all the money by the door of the
tent and left and then whenever my
friend woke up I told him what happened
and he was mad because all the money was
gone on the street this was crazy like
that yeah
it is crazy
the same guy whenever I try to get away
from him before when he had his knife
which led up to this story that I just
told you this little tidbit I just told
you he I tried to get away from him one
night and I was walking Hollywood
Boulevard try and stay on camera I
trying to stay in sight I went to in
front of the cameras of Hard Rock Cafe I
went in front of every camera that I
could find and he was following me so I
had to like keep a good eye out on him
and just changed sides of the street I
got away from that and then I took his
knife did this happened the night after
you and I spoke
yeah the same day oh yeah well no
actually um wait yes yes okay I think it
was um you mom I'm sorry according to
your mom because she had the date of the
arrest and then I looked at the date of
the videos the same day uh yeah my mom
doesn't know anything about how I'm
doing out here other than through Ben I
wish he'd just leave me the [ __ ] alone
honestly
I really do get [ __ ] sick of her
stalking me and trying to find out
everything little bit every little thing
about my life
mom I'm [ __ ] sick of you leave me the
[ __ ] alone what would you like to see
happen for you for Berlin from here yeah
I would love to just like maybe go to
rehab get a social worker get my own
place and start my life that's what I
would like to see happen I mean I would
go to rehab because you know people
can't just stop thinking about drugs did
you just you just don't stop thinking
about it you know you got to go to rehab
and get help
yeah I think they were actually quite a
few comments from people that were in
rehabs and therapists and all kinds of
people that offered up their their
services to you so maybe on this video
we can kind of get in touch with some of
those people
where do you think the chances are of
you sticking with the recovery program
and just falling to me chances of that
are very good because I feel I need it
are you clean right now cuz you've been
in jail for three yeah I am I mean would
I go back out there and do drugs no but
I still think I need rehab yeah in order
to get a social worker in order to get
my own place
the night that actually the same day
that you gave me the money for the
previous interview yes I went to buy
alcohol with it and I was in a frantic
mindset because nobody like I said
nobody gave a [ __ ] about me so I tried
to buy alcohol and I accidentally tried
to buy it with my food stamps card one
time and then I accidentally tried to
buy it with my social security one time
because I never have cash I never had
money in hand so I'm not used to having
money in hand
well Ben seems like a good friend yes
yes he's gonna let you stay with him for
a few days uh hopefully my court dates
tomorrow
Oh your birthday's tomorrow yeah which
is it's good that you're out yeah I mean
right now I think all I need to do is
well all I want to do right now cuz I
don't know how jails gonna go I just
wanted to smoke a blunt and eat and just
chill in a bed that's all I want to do
you can probably do two or three of
those maybe all three dents I'm sure boy
I want to go back to Hollywood you want
go back to the streets not the streets I
just want to walk around the Hollywood
Boulevard okay as long as you don't end
up in the same kind of as long as I'm
not there in the nighttime I think I'll
be alright because it gets cold at night
and I'm anemic so I can't really just
sleep on the streets with no blanket I
have to be in a tent or have a blanket
or walk around all night and deprive
myself of sleep and maybe sleep in the
Sun
but that's what the bracelets in jail
look like so tell me about jail what was
the worst part um I think the worst part
was being cold and being mistreated
probably coming off the drugs see right
uh yeah kind of yeah yeah
you been in jail before yes
that time was it also like your
medications might have been offer
something you weren't taking that may
have triggered that uh the first time I
went to jail in Florida I wasn't on any
medication actually I would just come
home drunk and uh get something to eat
and try to go to my room and my mom
would aggravate me to the fullest extent
to the point where I would throw my food
or yell or something because I believe
I'm autistic
and she would she never leaves me the
[ __ ] alone and then I get called the
cops called on me and then I go to jail
just because she doesn't want me home or
she needs a break or some [ __ ] like that
instead of just telling me to get out
she has a [ __ ] for you so she showed me
a picture of her backyard who was shed
I'm not going back home why the [ __ ]
should I have to stay in a shed why
can't I stay in that house you know I'm
just messages she wanted me to tell you
oh okay
I mean their lessons they're brand new
shed and unless it's in my name and
unless I'm we've left the [ __ ] alone
maybe but other than that no another
you're out you guys obviously I don't
know if I'll speak to her again all
right
the rehab do you think is where is it
the alcohol is the drugs is the whole
thing is it tell me what who do you
think is rehab it's song
I don't know I'll go for whatever they
think I need to go for it no probably
figure that out yeah
I mean Ben's nice enough to let me stay
with him so yeah he has a good nice guy
yes when I listen to your story the
first time what I heard and I'm not I
don't claim to be an expert but they
reminded me of like when I was maybe
your age and there were times where I
just could not love myself I just
refused I just couldn't get a handle on
loving myself
so you end up having these really dark
thoughts and then you know that's just
part of it you know growing up and
maturing and the age you're at you're 26
mm-hmm yeah and I see my daughters who
are younger than you slightly but going
through similar kind of emotions and I
almost think it's part of humans growing
up and as we age we mellow a little bit
but it doesn't make the pain that you're
in any less it is what it is you want to
know what I think what do you think I
think that nobody should have to grow up
I'm not gonna grow up I mean just cuz I
have a job and [ __ ] in the house and
everything I'm not gonna grow up yeah
well that's a healthy attitude too
that's that's why girl up yeah
I'm a lot older than you and I still
feel like I'm 20 years old I still think
I am I mean my mom would love to see me
grow up maybe that's why I don't want to
grow up she would love to see me blonde
maybe that's why I want to die all of my
hair black she'd love to see me in pink
but I'm not gonna be in pink what cares
you're like what color is your hair
naturally blonde yeah oh my god your
hair should be dyed yeah yeah it makes
it look fuller you know well just is
yours I can't imagine you as a blonde
well I'd love to help you out in some
way I guess we should see how the
hearing goes tomorrow is it yeah let's
see how that goes and then we'll not
we'll go from there
I think I think my viewers would love to
help you I would love to help you
I think it's thank you guys I'm very
kind about a lot of lovely very
supportive viewers that really care want
to see you do better
okay
killing well thank you for coming back
and
they will talk again after your hearing
let's do it
see how that goes okay all right Tracy
thanks thank you
you